hi i'm christine goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
the senate voting to move forward with
the second impeachment trial of former
president donald trump
with six republican lawmakers joining
democrats to say
they believe the trial is constitutional
fox news at night anchor and fox news
chief legal correspondent shannon breme
breaks down what to expect in the days
ahead and the arguments
on both sides of the aisle u.s
immigration and customs enforcement
reportedly preparing to issue new
guidelines to curb the deportations of
immigrants
for crimes including driving under the
influence or fraud
instead focusing on national security
threats in those convicted
of aggravated felonies fox national
correspondent william logioness
discusses
president biden's immigration agenda and
measures aimed at rolling back his
predecessor's policies
plus commentary from syndicated
columnist cal thomas
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we take a deeper look at
the stories important
to you you can subscribe on your
favorite podcast player
by going to foxnewspodcast.com i'm dana
perino i'm juan williams i'm kennedy and
this
is the fox news rundown
wednesday february 10th 2021
i'm lisa brady instead of case dismissed
the second
trump impeachment trial will continue
after an emotional opening listen this
is not like a regular trial or legal
proceeding it is so different in so many
ways it's much more political in nature
i'm dave anthony president biden is
changing more
trump-era policy on immigration it could
drive more migrants to our border
so if you incentivize people to come
here and you promise to give them health
care
and you know they're going to get a bus
ticket to go live with someone and then
they don't have to show up for their
their court appearance because
ice is not going to come get them
because there's no interior enforcement
if you keep your nose clean so why
wouldn't you come
and i'm cal thomas i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
the historic second impeachment trial of
now former president donald trump
opened with a flashback to the chaos and
violence of january 6
when the capital was attacked
house impeachment managers offering a
timeline of video evidence
as they argue the former president
incited insurrection
with his claims of a stolen election and
encouragement
to fight we will stop the steal
as congress prepared to certify the
electoral college results
though the video left out trump's appeal
to peacefully and patriotically make
their voices heard
you will not be hearing extended
lectures for me
because our case is based on cold
hard facts but the lead impeachment
manager maryland congressman jamie
raskin
did get personal breaking down as he
explained how one of his grown daughters
invited to witness the peaceful transfer
of power that day
reacted and i promised her that it would
not be like this again
the next time she came back to the
capitol with me
and you know what she said she said dad
i don't want to come back to the capitol
the defense team for the former
president condemned the capital attack
and the rioters who carried it out
but they argue that trump's words at a
rally near the capitol were
figurative and attorney bruce caster
says the trial is political
the majority in the house of
representatives does not want to face
donald trump
as a political rival in the future
that's the real reason we're here
attorney david shone also hitting
critics of the former president for talk
of deprogramming trump supporters
but at the end of the day this is not
just about donald trump
or any individual this is about our
constitution
and abusing the impeachment power for
political gain
they also argue that trump was denied
due process rights after the house voted
to impeach without holding any hearings
and they say the trial is
unconstitutional now that he's out of
office
but after tuesday's opening round the
senate voted to let the trial continue
six republicans
joining democrats and finding the trial
is constitutional
just over a month since the deadly siege
at the same building
one of the first things you learn as a
law student and as a young attorney is
you want to emotionally connect with
your jury if you can
shannon bream is the fox news at night
anchor and fox news chief legal
correspondent
and this is no ordinary jury these are
senators
who lived through that day who were also
worried about their staff and themselves
and their family and friends who may
have been around the capitol so
to take them back to that day was a very
effective
opening salvo in this whole thing but
they're also not a typical jury in that
most of them have probably made up their
minds about whether this is
or isn't constitutional and whether
they're ultimately going to vote to
convict
so you have to wonder who the argument
is for then and i think
much of that video was also aimed at a
broader audience to the american people
it is something that for the democrats
really rallies them is this opposition
to now former president trump
um they find it to be a unifying thing
so um you've got the jury there in front
of you the senators but i think that
this video was intended for a much
broader
wider audience do you expect them
to maybe keep coming back to that even
at the risk of maybe traumatizing
some of the members who did live through
it i do think it's an effective
tool in taking people back to the
emotions of that day
to the worries that they had um and to
to intersperse that with what the
president was saying or what he was
suggesting
but i think the timeline is really uh
important because you have to know
what he was saying what he was saying it
uh at the timing of when people were
actually going on that incursion
into the to the capitol that turned
violent and deadly in several cases
so there are already people who are
raising uh
you know concerns and are raising
objections to the video that was shown
in the house saying uh
that it violates laws about or at least
procedures and rules about what can be
shown uh over in congress when it comes
to editing video
so they're going to be objections to it
but i would definitely expect to see
more snippets of it just
as the president's team now former
president trump's team is going to use
video they think makes their case as
well
one of his attorneys bruce castor said
they changed their strategy
i'll be quite frank with you we changed
what we were going to do on account that
we thought that the house manager's
presentation
was well done and i wanted you to know
that we have responses to those things
do you think the defense responded
successfully so far
i think they seemed a little bit
scattered i think that
you may have something planned but again
that these attorneys have not had weeks
and months to work on this much like the
house managers
have and knew who they were putting
together that team has been solidified
for several weeks as this went through
the house
uh and then prepping for the senate you
know the president has had some
difficulty in keeping his
legal team together and so they're going
to be less prepared they're just simply
going to have less time to be ready to
meet these
um you know arguments as they come
so it was a powerful video i think for
everybody who saw it
regardless of whether your support of
the president or somebody who opposes
him
it was a terrible day for this country
so it was a very effective opening
argument
and i do think uh his team at least
bruce castor seemed a little rattled a
little scattered in how he was going
about
his uh joan i think seemed much more
um organized and sticking to his script
and pretty much sounded like he was
going to get to the arguments about
whether this whole thing is
constitutional or not
uh and really dig out facts and
precedent and stick to the script for
what he had planned
i know the president's defense team was
quick to say they condemn
the attack on the capitol and denounce
the rioters
you will not hear any member of the team
representing
former president trump say anything
but in the strongest possible way
denounce the violence of the
rioters and those that breached the
capital how difficult it is for them to
be only to say that
you know in words though when they're
essentially up against
all of that video evidence of how bad it
was
and i think it was it was a smart thing
for them to do right out of the gate to
say
from the president on down we want
nothing to do with this we
distanced from this the president is
said that day the violence wasn't okay
they're going to try to obviously point
to those statements
and to their complete you know
distancing from what happened that day
um
so i think you listen this is not like a
regular trial or legal proceeding it is
so different in so many ways it's much
more political in nature
so you're not looking at the same sort
of setup as you would have say in a
criminal trial this is going to be very
different
and i think that the house managers who
are
you know prosecuting this case
essentially if you want to use that word
against former president trump
are going to weigh on emotions they are
going to make
i think political entreaties as well i
think that they're going to want
these senators to think very much about
their political future and what it means
and what kind of statement they're
making with these votes
i think there's some senators who have
been very clear about how they feel and
nothing they see
is going to change their vote for or
against this but i think there are maybe
five or ten there that
are persuadable especially among the
republicans
the problem is the democrats need to get
far beyond that to actually get to a
conviction
it doesn't look like right now they'll
be able to do it
yeah i wanted to ask you if you thought
any mines had been changed
on day one because the vote
uh to say that the trial is
constitutional and can
continue ended up being 56 to 44.
so there were six republicans who sided
with democrats to say
yes the cut the trial is constitutional
does that make it seem like maybe they
won some republicans over or were those
six
republicans um always going to
vote that way and letting it continue
well they had a similar procedural vote
a couple weeks ago if you'll remember
that was put up by gop senator rand paul
and i think the vote fair was 55-45 so i
think they um picked up an additional
vote i think it was senator bill cassidy
uh out of louisiana who sided with
democrats so they expect that it would
probably be a very similar vote to what
they saw
a couple of weeks ago with a handful of
republicans crossing over to say
this is not to our ultimate vote whether
we'll say to convict or not but we do
think
this proceeding is legitimate the senate
trial so they've won over at least one
more
in bill cassidy than they had a couple
of weeks ago so where
that goes and whether they get any
closer to the 17 they need is doubtful
but you have a number of republican
senators saying listen this is a process
we think is
important for the country it meets
constitutional muster
we're going to treat it with legitimacy
and move forward one of the republicans
who voted to let it continue was someone
who had been
a frequent critic of the former
president senator ben sasse
but it was interesting that during the
defense initial arguments
attorney bruce castor actually called
him out the honorable gentleman from
nebraska mr sass
i saw that he faced backlash back home
because of a vote he made some
weeks ago the political party was
complaining about
a decision he made as a united states
senator suggesting he could pay
a political price is that a you know the
defense's way of putting political
pressure
on republicans who might be tempted to
vote to convict
kind of reminding them that the former
president remains popular in the party
it could be i think that that moment
where he was
talking about nebraska there was some
confusion it seemed like uh
senator benfast from nebraska um senator
deb fischer who
also is from nebraska turned around and
said something to him it looked like
there was some confusion over
you know kind of what is he getting out
by bringing this up but i would say if
you want to put political pressure on
anybody ben sasse is not the right
person if anything i think it will
backfire on you
um he is a very um immovable kind of guy
once he is settled on a principle
and um he's always been much more about
the constitution about the country than
he is any particular
leader or lawmaker or president and
that's
really the core of where he comes from
so i think any attempt to try to move
him on political pressure or
you know perceived harassment or
bullying on hey
you know former president trump is still
calling the shots for the gop
i don't think that will work on ben tess
if there aren't enough votes to convict
and again that's no one seems to think
that's likely
could there be enough votes to still do
what democrats want as a possible
punishment
and disqualify trump from holding office
again
or does it really take a conviction to
get to that point
yeah my understanding is from all the
true experts on impeachment which i am
not
that you do have to get past that first
hurdle you're going to have to get to 67
votes
to convict or as our true capitol hill
expert chad pergram our producer and
reporter over there says
you gotta have two-thirds of the votes
of those presents so it may not be 67
but we're assuming all hundred
senators have a vote there you gotta get
to 67 to get the conviction and only
then can you get to the next step which
would be to ban him from running for
federal office again
so again it's interesting that you gotta
think that democrats know and
republicans know you're probably not
getting to 67. it would take
um something very surprising that we had
not anticipated or seen thus far
so if you can't get to that it means you
can't get to the question of whether to
bar him from public office so how much
of this
is just another public thrashing of
former president trump and his followers
how much of this is political will all
of impeachment is pretty much political
how likely is it do you think that
either side
will end up calling witnesses or that
the senate will even
allow it at this point it doesn't seem
like they're going to go there you know
we've had a couple of republicans
including senator lindsey graham who
headed up the judiciary committee who
has been
for the most part a close friend and
supporter and defender of the president
um he certainly was not on the issue of
january 6 and felt the president should
have done
much more in that moment um but even he
has said listen you guys want to do this
if you want to start calling witnesses
great
you're going to open that door we'll
make this last week's we will call all
kinds of witnesses
and technically the senate apparently is
not supposed to conduct other business
while it is conducting an impeachment
trial
so you have to wonder how much either
side is going to really have the stomach
for tying everything up
it's the first 100 days for president
biden they have judicial non-nominations
other kind of confirmations that they
need to get through
um so i think that there's going to have
to be a discussion among democratic
leadership about whether they want to
open that pandora's box when it comes to
witnesses
fox's shannon bream folks don't miss her
on the live in the brim podcast
love the name of your podcast shannon
and um thanks for
spending some time with us on the
rundown great to be with you thank you
so much
this is cal thomas with your fox news
commentary coming up
president biden has been in office three
weeks now
and he's issued dozens of executive
orders and actions basically
the best way to describe them to undo
the damage trump has done and that
includes immigration policy
he stopped border wall construction and
tried to put a temporary halt to
deportations but that's on hold after
texas sued
now the biden administration is readying
new guidance for immigration and customs
enforcement
that's expected to direct ice agents to
only focus on deporting those here
illegally
who are national security risks or
convicted of aggravated felonies
or gang members white house press
secretary jen saki
nobody is saying that duis or assault
are acceptable
behavior and those arrested for such
activity should be tried and sentenced
as appropriate by local law enforcement
but we're talking about the
prioritization of who is going to be
deported from the country but in texas
jackson county sheriff h.a louderback is
upset
some migrants are now being allowed to
enter the u.s even without covid tests
telling fox in the haste to open the
border
for everyone uh in this company uh
the i mean this is uh this is
something that i expected to some degree
it's not clear exactly when the expected
new guidance for ice will be made
official
we've all heard of sanctuary cities and
states this is almost a sanctuary nation
william logginess is a fox national
correspondent based in los angeles who's
reported from the border and south of it
numerous times including last week
the byte administration is proposing
that the only
individuals that ice go after
in their words to spend precious
resources
are individuals who number one our
national security threat or number two
are being released from on a conviction
from state prison or federal prison
or potentially jail on an aggravated
felony or violent felony
so let's just say under california
sanctuary law
if you've been arrested for a violent
felony
you could be subject to ice deportation
but they've raised that up even farther
by saying it must be a convicted
felon but that also means let's look at
the people
who are not on that list kidnapping
robbery burglary
um dui these are not considered violent
felonies
so those individuals can be arrested and
or convicted
and serve time but they will not be
turned over to ice
for deportation okay so in this case
you're talking about you know biden
policy under the
trump administration there was a lot of
concern
in immigrant communities about ice
agents just going in and just
grabbing people who were here illegally
and and getting rid of them
was that something that really was
happening
oh it's misleading i mean ice does they
have a they have something called
um ero which is enforcement removal
operations and fugitive task force
almost exclusively ice
was only going after individuals i mean
90 percent of the deportations in 2020
under ice um ero
let me say that arrests because there
were other deportations coming off the
border but the point is
is 90 were arrested for
or convicted of a felony all right let's
go to the border i know
you recently had gone down in the
mexican border
when you were in california what's the
situation there now because
there are changes in policy when it
comes to deportation and how we handle
migrants coming here what have you found
out
so it's um so as we know
candidate biden said a lot of stuff that
said many things that were perceived
as being conducive to
a much warmer reception when you came to
the border
immigrants know this stuff they have
relatives on this side of the board who
are texting them
or calling them telling them what the
status is here
but they also have smugglers who who
basically live in their community
who recruit individuals who may want to
come north so what has happened
what i'm told agents say since
basically the election
when joe biden won they have seen a
steady
their words a steady increase in
apprehensions along the border
people are coming now the by
administration says hey we're not ready
for you yet
we need to get our asylum rules and
regulations in place
before we can process you now they did
promise to
resume asylum process which was
generally suspended under president
trump
partially because of this rule 42 which
says that uh
because of kovid uh the board of parole
is not taking anyone into custody
they're knowing they're not apprehending
anyone they'll stop you at the border
they'll initiate you in the field take
your fingerprint
and then take you immediately to the
nearest port of entry
and send you back to mexico so two
things are happening
you have a surge of migrants coming from
central america
up to the border they're not able to get
in or they're getting in and then
they're being returned
so mexico is having a huge problem along
its
northern border with us as people are
camping out they're filling the shelters
they're obviously springing covered with
it mexico is the third highest uh
covert rate in the in the world and
mexico is now beginning to tell the
united states listen
we can no longer handle deported
families with tender age
age under 12. families back here because
our resources
are maxed to the limit they actually
even passed a a rule
or law that they would not take back
families of with that status now it's
only happening for some reason
in some areas of texas del rio and
mcallen texas or reynosa so right now
we're having this situation where you've
heard of the term catch and release and
so what's happening
is you have a lot of families coming
over the united states border patrol
cannot handle them in their processing
facilities because the covid
has reduced capacity by 75 percent so
they are being let out they are be given
they're being taken to a bus station
uh by the border patrol or ice
they're given a bus ticket to go live
with relatives somewhere in the united
states
the one caveat there which is so unusual
is
as we know if you're an international
traveler you coming into
new york or la or any other
international airport you must have a
negative
covid test within 72 hours of arrival
however
we are not testing these migrant
families who we are taking in taking to
the bus station
and giving them a ticket so we don't
know whether they have covered or not
okay so you're talking about so you're
talking about in texas
people under the current administration
who are stopped at the border are we
talking about just people under 12 are
we talking about adults as well
entire families they're given bus
tickets and then they're on their way in
the u.s somewhere
families that's correct not single
adults
single adults are still being returned
to mexico okay
all right so families have a criminal
record they'll be turned over to ice
so they're not breaking the family up
they're keeping the family together and
saying right they'll give them a
mta a notice to appear at some future
date
in court to have their asylum claim be
heard
and so if you incentivize people to come
here and you promise to give them health
care
and you know they're going to get a bus
ticket to go live with someone and then
they don't have to show up for their
their court appearance because
ice is not going to come get them
because there's no interior enforcement
if you keep your nose clean
so why wouldn't you come there was a
debate
a couple of years ago about these uh
ntas as you talk about
notice to appear and people uh you know
who were trump defenders were saying
look nobody
really shows up to these hearings and
then they're lost and they're gone
somewhere and they're just in the us
is that true or not no so what was
happening in
in this this is trump's fault for
misstating the facts but
to go through a full immigration hearing
can take five or six appearances
immigrants would typically show up for
the early
court appearances until it was obvious
that they were not going to be allowed
to stay so the one they wouldn't show up
for
was the last one which would have been
they could have been taken into custody
so the what what trump would have been
more accurate to say
is 90 of those who come here claiming
for asylum
are not removed so we've heard about you
know caravans
even in january that we're coming here
how many
are there a lot of caravans on the way
yes there are caravans
because i've been on three of them right
now i believe
there's three thousand five
apprehensions
per day along the southwest border
so that's telling you what people are
continuing to come
and we're continuing to catch them and
generally remove them
so caravans began to be developed
because the cartels control
the territory just south of the border
you're not going to make it to the
border without paying
somebody something that's the way it
works so
what they would do is when you get a
caravan of you know
two 3 000 people well the cartels
couldn't control that neither can police
so they would overwhelm all these border
checkpoints
um guatemala i mean we've got to give a
lot of credit
to guatemala for stopping the last
caravan and then mexico has really
beefed up
its southern border because the problem
they have on their northern border so
if you're considering right now going
north do you want to try to go
with a caravan which is so big and
obvious guatemala police and military
cannot ignore
it international media has got a
spotlight on you
i think you have a better chance going
alone
somewhere along the border than going
with a group of five thousand people
but then again you're putting your life
at the hands of a smuggler or someone
who's
you have to pay yeah but that's that's
that's the way it's always been
i mean i mean you can't really well i
say you can't expect
that's that's just the way it is that's
the price of admission if you will
and generally speaking and this is funny
most of us don't understand it if you're
a if you're a honduran
or guatemalan and you're suddenly in the
middle of mexico you don't know where
the heck you are
you don't know one direction on the next
and the people where's north
right so they don't know not only do
they not know mexico they don't know the
border
the people who do are the smugglers they
know when to move you
and sometimes they'll move you as a
cover for drugs
depends on how much you pay are you a
high high interest target are you one of
these guys from iran or yemen or
somewhere else
but nevertheless you're not your chances
of making it over the border
without a guide are nil this is not
going to happen
but you've been in these care events
you've talked to these people all of all
of this risk and danger
and unknown is worth it to them it is
it is i mean they've you know i mean not
just
mention about the hurricanes but it's
generally
wages you can make you know two dollars
a day
or seven dollars an hour okay in the us
and so if there is no employment at all
um and there's a lot of corruption and
there is some danger
depending on who you are and where you
are
but it's generally poverty these are
economic migrants
not to say there are not some who are
fleeing actual violence or
or threats from the gangs etc uh that
can happen or maybe domestic violence
situation
but that is by no means the majority
very interesting william laginess fox
national correspondent based in la
thank you so much for joining us you bet
thanks
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever changing times you can rely
on fox news for hourly updates for the
very latest news and information
on your time listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind during the
rebellious 1960s the slogan power to the
people became a mantra for the young
to protest what they saw as oppression
from their elders
now comes a moment when significant
numbers of americans
can exercise real power in ways that
will improve the country
most people will never attain a level of
influence comparable to a president
a member of congress a supreme court
justice a newspaper editor or a tv
network anchor or reporter
but ultimate power does not reside in
any of these institutions or professions
it resides in we the people the pandemic
has given especially parents of young
children an opportunity to seize power
they already possessed
but have never fully exercised with
teachers unions dictating when or if
public schools will open again
parents are discovering the power of
educating their children at home
there they cannot only teach the real
history of the country
as opposed to the revisionist version
now taught in too many schools
but add a moral foundation that secular
public schools no longer provide
according to one estimate in the spring
of 2019
the last period for which figures are
available two and a half million
children in grades k
through 12 were homeschooled the trend
over the last few years amounts to an
estimated annual homeschooling growth
rate of between two
and eight percent that may not sound
like much when you consider that 48.6
million k-12 students
attend public schools according to the
census bureau but
it suggests momentum combine
homeschooling
families with a 5.7 million students
attending private schools
and you might call it a movement
homeschooling is much easier today than
it used to be
not only are there substantial online
resources many parents are combining
their skills and backgrounds with other
parents
if one is deficient in history or math
another parent with knowledge of these
subjects can contribute
many of these subjects have been tainted
by political correctness and in the case
of history
revisionism conservatives who want to
preserve america from what they regard
as
incremental socialism should embrace
homeschooling
as a way to rescue the next generation
and preserve the country
i've quoted her before but this bears
repeating the late barbara bush said
your success as a family our success as
a nation
depends not on what happens inside the
white house but on what happens
inside your house bush understood where
real power comes from
now if more people will only seize that
power and use it
i'm cal thomas
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa just say
alexa play news from fox in fox news
it's the latest when you need it on
demand
from fox news and amazon alexa love fox
news
click the subscribe button to get more
of the news and opinion you trust and
click the fox news rundown playlist for
the latest episodes